that's Buddhist belief treat others as
you would like to treat your mother I
believe in that stuff whatever religion
or genre practice or thesis believes in
doing the right thing and doing right by
others and then the universe takes over
and brings you value I actually think
it's not some karma cosmic thing I think
it's actually quite practical would it
not make sense to our practical brains
that if you're doing something good for
somebody else that that puts you in a
leveraged position for something good to
happen to you I'm actually not very
romantic or cosmic or Spacey or Zena
fide around providing people value like
I love karma I believe in it because I
believe Karma's [ __ ] practical how
about that because I believe Karma's
practical I believe that if you do
something good for somebody else if you
provide them value if you're if you're
taking their time and providing them
with good thoughts and good themes and
good strategies and good outlooks and
seeing white space I believe that the
people that started snapchat design
agencies building filters oh it broke
out I believe that the people that went
out and built snapchat design filter
agencies that have been making money
over the last month because they listen
to me
yeah I believe that they'll they'll say
good things about me that will make more
people pay attention I believe that
they'll tell clients to work with me I
believe that they'll tell their sister
that's talented or their brother that
sounded to go work for Boehner or intern
there yes I do believe that doing the
right thing is practical
you